a road rage incident caught on camera as  a woman allegedly fires a gun into a  vehicle where a toddler was seated  it happened on july 26th on interstate  45 in houston texas sheriff ed gonzalez  says two vehicles were driving north  when they came to a stop that's when a  man and woman got out of their truck and  approached another man in his car the  victim says the man later identified as  34-year-old benjamin greene assaulted  him sheriff gonzalez says that as the  man tried to drive off the female  suspect 40-year-old nazli ortiz fired a  gun into the back seat through the  passenger window the victim says his  two-year-old son was seated in the back  of the vehicle at the time  the victim was taken to the hospital  with a possible graze wound sheriff  gonzalez says both ortiz and greene were  arrested and now face assault charges  for the latest developments in this  story and all things true crime stay  with long crime network i'm sierra  gillespie